our next guest british actress erin
doherty is getting rave reviews for her
role in the new series chloe doherty is
known for playing princess anne in the
award-winning hit series the crown and
now she's taking on a darker role she
plays becky a young woman obsessed with
stalking her one-time teenage friend
chloe online after chloe's mysterious
death becky assumes a new identity sasha
to get close friends to get close to
chloe's friends and find out what really
happened to her
in this clip becky's new friend josh
starts getting suspicious after she used
a different fake name at another party
so you like to give false names at
parties sorry i was just having fun uh
yeah obviously
so which one is your real name sasha can
we stop playing games you're the one
playing games i'm just trying to keep up
what can i get you
um can i get two lattes please josh what
do you want i'm fine thank you okay
i said i'm sorry it's just really hard
to trust anything you say now
[Music]
becky green
wow
so good aaron daugherty joins us now uh
okay so you play becky who's one kind of
person yeah we meet her right away and
then she transforms into sasha to sashay
into these amazing parties and amazing
homes this incredible group of people
what was it like
shifting as an actor between these two
characters well like you say as an actor
i i kind of got it like that's what i do
um so i i really related to that ability
to just kind of
i don't know i think what do people call
it like code switching or something yeah
yeah like it's kind of like built into
the job description of of being an actor
and it was really
fun to actually
get to play that like because very often
you're just going okay this is my
character these are my beliefs and you
just do that whereas with this character
there's like a wealth of just like rich
intricate and she's she's like scanning
the internet to find information on
chloe her old friend to kind of
investigate her death she's obsessive
about it and someone called the
character a cross between the talented
mr ripley and walter middy which reminds
me that usually men play these sort of
weirdos and this is not yeah and i love
your weirdo or the character i'll take
that
i love playing weirdos like honestly and
like you say like i think i jumped at
the opportunity to be a part of it
because it's so rare that
me personally but i also think like you
say women
get to play these intricate personas
yeah and we are just the same as men
like we have the complete complexity
within us to to
get this obsessive about people or
things or whatever it may be and like i
say i just was so chuffed to be given
the opportunity oh it's so
transformative i was completely last
night i was watching the first episode
and i was literally getting nervous like
you're going to get caught in the
livestream
how do you get out of the lie how do you
get out of the lie there there's so much
richness here already
is it relatable to i mean i the social
stalking the social media stalking
aspect that that people can look at that
go i've oh god i've kind of done that
yeah like that again that's what i find
exciting about it because i just think
uh i think our relationship with social
media is constantly evolving and i think
to highlight this behavior is really
important i think like because i've got
a younger brother and i think all the
pressure that comes with like getting
likes and having followers and just
portraying these amazing lives like
it's important to also go it's okay that
that isn't your life and i don't think i
don't think we need to continue in this
vein of going like we need to right
prove something yeah yeah it's just not
it's not
doable and this show proves that it's
not healthy it's a fake world that you
create on there yeah you had to become a
little bit more active on social media
to prepare for this role what was that
like you know somebody who might not be
as active typically it was odds like i
really i had to download the app because
i didn't even have that app on my phone
congratulations well i don't know
like i made the decision really early on
again i think having a younger sibling
made me kind of go right i definitely
don't want that relationship with it but
when this opportunity came up i had to
i was going on it every morning and i
would just spend hours like scrolling
and i don't even know what i was looking
at like
social media people get a date yeah
right but you then you also recognize
the darker side yeah because it just
swallows your time you should have
looked up all the wonderful comments
about you being prince anne in the oh
yeah
no honestly yeah yeah yeah it was
strange it was so strange but um it was
really really helpful to to just
understand
that place that you get into when you're
so dependent
on just seeing what other people are
doing right
we're looking at pictures of you uh from
the crown uh
olivia coleman uh plays the queen yeah
in that season what was uh like working
with her
honestly she is
she's one of the most incredible people
she's amazing i love her in the lost
daughter yeah yes oh my gosh that film
everything she does everything she does
um but yeah she is a really just
gorgeous human being and to learn
from her on that set like she just she
was number one and she didn't
she didn't make anyone aware of it she
just loves her job but she doesn't like
any of the faf around it she was like oh
i think i was on that job when she won
the oscar
and she came into the makeup trailer
that morning and everyone was like woo
and she was like oh shut up
like i was like as if but that's so
inspirational that she just doesn't it's
not about that for her but you knew she
was number one because she had it
written on her dressing room door
but she probably didn't ask for it
to be taken away
wow that's funny yeah aaron daugherty
thank you very much for being here the
show is terrific it's chloe premieres
friday june 24th on prime video